a primary school in edinburgh has asked
boys and male teachers to wear
skirts for a day to promote gender
equality well it certainly got a mixed
response from the parents
extremely creepy so pleased i haven't
got any children going to that school
hope authorities are contacted about
this disgusting decision
my son goes to the school and decided he
wanted to wear a skirt and support this
case should be praised not frowned on i
can't believe the vile single-minded
comments that some people have made
thankfully my kids are not part of your
school you should keep your deranged
thoughts to yourself and not thrust them
onto primary school children shameful
behavior
well done castleview proud of my
daughter and her friends for asking for
this they are more mature than a lot of
the narrow-minded hate thrown at them
today brilliant school working towards
teaching inclusivity for all
as we can show you here on the programme
several of the male teachers at
castleview school in edinburgh went
along with the idea it was inspired by
the wearer skirt to school day in spain
held as a protest after a
fifteen-year-old and bilbao was expelled
for wearing one and castleview says it's
all about freedom of expression
we're keen to spread the message that
clothes don't have a gender and that we
should all be free to express ourselves
as we choose
however richard lucas are the leader of
the scottish family party believes the
initiative will only increase the
already large number of children
suffering from gender confusion
what's happening in western culture at
the moment is there is a move to see any
gender distinction as a problem and to
try and subvert it and to overcome it in
one way or another
and now as i say whether or not the end
result
might be positive or negative i feel it
probably isn't positive in most cases
trying to use children as part of that
process at a stage where there is
where skirts are clearly seen as female
clothing so you're saying to a boy
basically dressed as a girl that's very
unhelpful because gender confusion is an
epidemic in the western world at the
moment there's a massive increase in the
number of children and young people who
are
experiencing gender confusion they're
being referred to clinics going on to
various so-called treatments it's a
problem that can blight them through the
rest of their life
according to the school principal the
request came from students themselves so
she posted some of them online one girl
wrote that she heard about the bilbao
case and wanted her school to have a
wear skirt stay too
the edinburgh city council has spoken
out in support of the school stressing
that no one was forced to wear a skirt
richard lucas again thinks children are
being used to advance the school's woke
agenda
this impression that this came from the
children is basically dishonest
these are young children they're led by
the teacher in the direction the teacher
wants to lead them in and then basically
the staff are dishonest in claiming that
this came from the the children in some
sort of organic manner it didn't at all
it's the staff using the children to
advance their own agenda
this is a state school all government
schools in scotland which is where you
know probably over 90 percent of
children go to
uh then they all have to have this sort
of lgbt inclusive
education approach
so parents can't opt out of this by
choosing a different school because all
schools have this this gender lgbt
agenda and it's been pushed onto
to young people they're frightened to
send their children to school because of
the just sheer indoctrination that will
take place in them
you